[Music]
well for decades only crackpots and
crazy people believed in UFOs that's
what I thought anyway and then in recent
years it turns out that governments have
been taking them seriously all along
very seriously Nick Pope is a journalist
who has spent years researching UFOs for
the British government he says that UFOs
aren't just real they also frequently
come close to crashing into commercial
airliners among other things Nick Pope
joins us tonight Nick thank you very
much for coming on so it's really not a
question of jus governments believe us
those UFOs are real yes they do the
United States government does the
British government does the question is
do they have any idea what they are
where they're from no we don't we keep
an open mind on it we don't rule
anything off you know take nothing off
the table with this our point really is
that whatever these things turn out to
be there is a serious defence national
security and air safety issue here yes
well so that's kind of the nub of it and
that is the clue that that's where my
interest comes from so why aren't
governments encouraging the population
to if they say about terrorism if you
see something say something report
sightings to the government so we can
make sense of this potential threat well
they should be and that's what we
certainly did at the Ministry of Defense
for many years we took it very seriously
our own pilots were seeing these things
we were having radar operators tracked
them and we knew again through
intelligence and through open source
material we knew that the Russians and
the Chinese and others were working on
this too the problem was that just the
pop culture baggage from the term UFO
flying saucer little green men people
don't take it seriously but they should
so we've ruled out I think that these
are aircraft experimental aircraft or
technically advanced aircraft from other
countries is that true well no we keep
an open mind as I say and and some of
these things probably are Russian or
Chinese whoever it is but the
to the point we must find out it there's
something in our airspace we need to
know for years government said they
didn't do this they did I did it for the
British government I can only talk about
this now because my old employers are
gradually declassifying and releasing
information about my old job we now know
of course the Pentagon had a program - I
think it will take congressional
hearings to get to the bottom of all
this not just in in the United States
but all around the world and I'd like to
see those congressional hearings
commercial pilots have very often
reported sighting objects in the air
that seems to defy the laws of physics
to what extent are these objects a
threat to commercial aviation
potentially we'll certainly the British
Ministry of Defence and our Civil
Aviation Authority which is the UK
equivalent of your FAA have dozens of
cases in our files about near misses
some of which where pilots have had to
take evasive action and again it comes
back to the point I don't care in one
sense what these things are but when
there is this flight safety a concern
when we have these near misses we sure
as heck should be doing more to find out
that's for sure Nick Pope really one of
the most credible experts on this
subject I hope you will come back on our
show I appreciate it good to see you